standards are slipping a Buckingham
Palace behind the grand facade the
electrics haven't been replaced since
1949 and that's just the start of a
backlog of repairs both here and across
the royal estate that would cost around
50 million pounds to put right the
boilers at Buckingham Palace have not
been renewed for 60 years if you think
of the Victorian Albert Moore's eleum
outside the Albert Hall we've known for
18 years that you have got to do serious
work at that that hasn't happened
Windsor Castle with a problem with the
bedrooms and the Royal picture gallery
or too often they have buckets because
of the water coming through maybe the
Queen's more like the rest of us than we
ever realized not only have vital
repairs at properties like these been
put off the households also been
spending beyond its means the Queen gets
a sovereign grant from the taxpayer it
was 31 million pounds in 2012-2013 to
support her public duties but in the
same year the royal household spent 30
3.3 million and drew down 2.3 million
from its reserve fund leaving only 1
million pounds in contingency left an
all-time low and it won't go far given
the scale of what's needed so how
serious a condition are some of these
palaces and buildings in well the
palaces are in what is termed an
unacceptable condition and the thing is
it's very complicated to renovate a
Royal Palace it's not like you and me
they can't just pop down to the DIY
store get a bit of paint and you do it
up that way it's a really difficult
issue it costs a fortune to do up
somewhere like Buckingham Palace to do
the windows to the roof it's a massive
undertaking because these are also
working palaces and they can't just move
out so the actual concert to think is a
bit of a nightmare
the royal household blames the cost on
one-off events like the Diamond Jubilee
occasions like this generate millions of
pounds for British tourism but the
committee wants a lot more and point to
attractions like the Tower of London
which already pay for their keep Len
peas 8 years ago said to the palace you
need to open up packing palace to
tourists all year round and they
point-blank refused can I think it's
time the government simply told them
it's our building it belongs to the
nation not to you it we're going to open
it up and that way you'll raise the
money to do the maintenance the irony is
the Queen is one of the richest women in
the world but without better financial
management from those around her some of
our finest buildings could be left
crumbling Rachel younger Sky News
central London